- The IP rights?
- [Set Free] Well, what happened is,
it was me and Ron English.
So Ron English does,
he's one of those artists like,
one of those modern day
artists like him and Kaws that
it's an honor for them
to draw their stuff.
- Of course.
- And they don't come after 'em.
- I totally understand.
- He did Simpsons, he was actually
in an episode of the Simpsons.
- This is fucking amazing.
- Thank you, man.
- This looks so crazy.
So what's it do?
- Nothing it just--
- That's it, this is it?
I get it, I get it.
- This is the first time anyone's seen it.
- Yeah, we're debuting it right here.
(laughing)
- Fucking dropping exclusives around here.
Dude, it's fresh.
How much is it gonna be?
- $6.50.
- Love it.
- [Set Free] We're gonna do--
- [Gary] Tyler, I want one.
- [Set Free] Oh, totally.
- Let's buy one.
- We're doing a painting,
he did a painting.
We're doing prints.
I did a situation with New
Era and they're actually
going to make purple hats to match it.
And I'm going all out.
Just trying to, we're doing a record.
- How many of those?
- We're doing 500 of 'em to start.
And then we're doing--
- Let's buy them all and then
price them the next day for...
(laughing)
- It would work, totally.
- I know it would.
- It would kill 'em.
So ended up doing two records.
I did one record with Smoke
DZA, Dave East, Curren$y and
Styles P called Inhale Exhale.
- Love it.
- And then another record done
with Westside Gunn and Conway
and Alchemist did the beat.
Because toys never had something like--
- You're preaching.
- So, I'm excited man.
You take weed out of hip
hop I don't know if we're
gonna have good albums.
(laughing)
- There might be some truth to that.
- That's right.
- His office up in The Bronx I mean it--
- I wanna come through.
- Yeah we gotta get you there.
- I gotta, I know I know I
always look at you and then
like I never have no time but like.
How do we do it?
You know what?
I should go to, you know what?
I've been on like a real kick.
- Yankees Game?
- Yeah I've been wanting
to do a Yankees game
with Pli and Al.
Just like, I never do anything
for real life anymore.
So why don't I go to a Yankee game--
- It's right across the street.
- You're there in 20 minutes.
- Yeah exactly.
While my fantasy team
is still good and I'll
actually have a good
time at the Yankee game.
Why don't we pick a Yankee game in,
what are we in?
May, late May, early June and then--
- And he has the studio.
- Yeah exactly, I'll come
up there like 5:00, 5:30.
We'll chop for an hour and
then we'll go to the game.
- Yeah.
- And that'll be life.
- Perfect.
- OK, I wanna do that,
I've been wanting to.
- It's, yeah, it's fun.
- You would love it.
- Yeah, I know I see it.
I know it, I know I'll love it.
I just wanna come through.
- Yeah no, y'all--
- So when's this going,
when's this goin' up?
- 420.
Online only.
And um then I'ma do an
event with 100 and concepts,
to just give like people
to actually get the chance-
- How many, how many
are gonna be sold on 420
on the website?
- 900.
- So you made how many of those again?
- I mean, I'm sorry 400.
- That's alright, 400.
- Yeah, and then 100 on the website.
- It's probably gonna sell
out real quick, right?
- Oh, it's gone.
We sold, I did a black Charlie Brown.
- Yeah.
- We did 600 in three minutes.
- How do we make sure we buy one?
- I mean I just, ears to the street.
- Good.
- They'll be on Ebay the next
day for like $1200 bucks.
- Yeah.
- I get it man.
I really believe man, I actually wanna.
So, we got one that's free and
I think that's cool and that's fair.
But I wanna buy a couple more.
And if we get 'em, we get 'em.
If we don't we don't.
- No, you, I'll make sure.
- I know, but, I appreciate it.
- But it's actually, so there's
the thing called the blind bag.
So it's a couple different colors of 'em.
So these are the production that's
getting done in Hong Kong.
Then we're doing, those
are like the gold pot ones,
with the gold smiley face
and then the silver one.
So I'll make sure you get a whole set.
- Bet.
- I'll let you see 'em.
- Remember the old Woot.com?
Like surprise bullshit bag.
What'd they call it?
You guys are all too young for this?
- Yeah.
- That was the site
you kept talking about.
- Woot, Woot.com was
a game changer for me.
You remember Woot?
W-O-O-T back in the day?
- Yeah, I definitely remember the site.
- You were a kid right?
I remember it was some crazy shit like,
they'd have discounted shit.
It was, that was like the
early deal of the day shit.
That was the early Groupon.
- Amazon just started doing--
- Amazon bought Woot.
- And they just started doing,
Gabe was telling me yesterday they, like
fresh off the truck.
- That's super hard.
- They do one deal a day
and you like pick it up
at a certain location.
- Yeah.
- Nobody's in this game.
- How often do you drop a toy man?
- Well now my goal, this
year I got this one.
I'm looking at four this year.
One right now, this one.
I got another one coming
out with Star Wars.
- And how do you brand you and
your world in it if at all.
- Well this is prototype.
I'm gonna be, Compound
is gonna be on there.
- It will be on there.
- Yeah, Compound's on the toys.
What it was is like, I hooked up with,
I looked at the toy game
like mix-tapes right?
So a new artist wanna get in the game.
They're like, if I do a
mix-tape, I'm hot by myself but
I really gotta get co-signs from
other people for people to like me.
- You're talking about,
you're talking about life.
- Pretty much life.
- You're talking about life.
- So I did that with art and I said,
'cause I always collected,
collect, bought, love it.
I was like okay, let me get one.
Ron English is my first,
established artist.
And what it was is I
always felt, growing up,
of course I'm black.
- I've heard, I can see.
- You can see?
(laughing)
- No but go ahead.
- You watched the cartoons
were never no spins.
Flintstones was white, Jetsons was white.
Everything was white,
cool, we love it but,
so I was like okay, its never our culture.
- What about Fat Albert?
They came through heavy.
- Way later.
- I get it, I get it.
- Before Bill Cosby, way later.
(laughing)
So then, the second part I was like, well.
- I love Fat Albert.
- There's no hip-hop connected to it.
So I was like wow.
So the first toy we did, he had a
Charlie Brown who was regular with a grin.
I was like, let's make
a black Charlie Brown.
So then Charlie Brown was ill
and he did the pictures well.
And that was the one time
Charlie Brown had a hat on
with some swag, he turned it sideways.
- I remember it.
- And I was like yo.
Charlie Brown been
hiphop with the hat, so.
And then we broke Charlie
Brown down, he was like.
He was a rapper.
He had a whole squad.
(laughing)
- He had a gay guy, he had Puerto Rican
and he had a black guy.
And he was like, no matter
what happened he was the
coolest guy that everybody
wanted to hang with.
Lucy was a hater all the time.
(laughing)
- But he never kicked
her out of the group.
She kept moving the football.
And I was like yo, let's, wow,
let's do a black Charlie Brown.
- That's what's up.
- So we put a hat on him.
We put grills on him and
then, everybody loved it.
So then, you know, now
its like okay, SpongeBob.
Anybody who really watched
SpongeBob was high.
(laughing)
- 100%.
- 100%, so I was like
wow, there needs to be,
let's put that together.
Let's put a SpongeBob
and marijuana together
and now everybody is like, yo I remember.
We had, you had the
high As or, and like so.
Everything that I wanna do is,
one of the things I
look at be in marketing
is if you connect a culture to anything--
- The end, the end.
The end.
- So first one was cartoons,
now we're doing weed.
- I can't wait, I can't, I can't tell you.
I just can't 'cause it's
putting somebody on blast.
But you and I are gonna have a
real conversation in the fall
based on this entire thesis.
- Oh, wow.
- We're gonna do some business together.
- I'm ready.
- And you're gonna be real happy with me.
I got a real idea.
- I'm ready, I figure like you know,
I did it once before when I
created the AND1 mix-tape,
that I was like, I changed
the world, I changed culture.
- 100,000%.
100,000%.
- Thank you.
- That's just the truth.
- No, thank you so much.
- And by the way, it's
a replicatable thing.
- Yeah totally.
- Once you, 'cause you
just see the pattern.
- Yeah. That's and now I--
- It's what I do.
- Yeah, I'm doing it again in this lane.
- And that's fun for you because
it's like, its real to you.
- But you know what, so I gotta
question to ask everybody.
- Go 'head.
- What's your first love?
- My first love, was,
I can, I can figure this out.
Actually I wanna give you the real answer.
(sighing)
- I love this right here.
- It's a real good one.
- No, 'cause watch what I hit you with.
- My first love,
was probably...
Batman and Robin.
- Okay.
- The way you're talking about it.
My mom was my first love.
But the first thing I remember loving,
when we came, 'cause, I
wasn't born in America.
- Okay.
- So I was literally, do you
know what was going through
my mind right now?
The Great Space Coaster.
- Wow.
- Batman and Robin,
the old Adam West show.
- Okay.
With "pow" and all that.
- Flintstones, Price Is Right.
Those where the core things of how I
learned how to speak English.
- Okay.
- Those where things I liked,
that I loved, you know?
- And then the real one
like, those might be like,
do you know this is why I
wanna buy the New York Jets?
- Why?
- Probably my first love
is the New York Jets.
- Okay.
- Because that was the thing a year later,
that made all the other kids accept me.
And I was like now I'm an American.
- Cool.
- I'm an American.
- Okay so, I think everybody's wrong.
But I'll let them get their answer out.
- I love that.
- So--
- What's the answer?
- First thing that you love is a toy.
Your parents had you.
They put you in a crib.
They give you a teddy bear,
they give you something.
You don't remember these toys exactly.
- 100%.
- But your cerebral.
- Knows that.
- I believe that to be true.
And the best part is, you know,
for everybody listening.
A lot of people came from
nothing, like, I know for facts.
I had nothing, but the toy was, some
like fabric right?
- Yeah.
- It was a thing.
- It was something.
- It was a thing that you was--
- A blanket, a thing.
- So the thing with the
toy, when you love it.
It might of been a
pacifier with a bear on it.
It might of been a bottle with ears.
It was some type of toy.
- And everybody answers something that was
five or six or seven year old.
But the answer was one day old.
- It's one day.
It's no, it's literally like
three months, seven months.
- My man, it's why you
love your parents the most
even when they do the most fucked up shit.
- 'Cause was actually the first thing.
- First thing, yeah.
- And then, right?
- Then it was, whatever made you.
'Cause think about it.
- 'Cause you're going to
the first thing you loved
that was material outside of two humans
that popped you the fuck out.
- Right, exactly.
And they use this to shut you up.
- 'Cause the umbilical chord
is probably number one.
You're like yo, why you taking my shit?
- I love this,
(laughing)
No!
- That's actually the right answer.
(laughing)
- The umbilical chord.
- My man, you might have to
make an umbilical chord toy.
I better get some fucking
co-sign love on that.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause that's probably it.
- That's the first
thing you lose, in life.
- 100%.
- Wow, the first thing you lose in life.
We gotta trademark that.
(laughing)
- Okay yeah, listen, I mean,
you know why I'm so happy right now?
Because in 15 days I'm
going garage saleing
for the first time in the year.
- Wow.
- And that's like my opening day.
(mumbling)
And that is all I'm looking
for is shit like this.
Like finding like a, pop-culture,
1987 thing for 49 cents in somebody's box.
That's my jam jam jam.
My life, I get a bigger
high in two Saturdays,
three Saturdays, 'cause today's
Friday, three Saturdays,
I will get a bigger high by buying,
I bought a fucking ThunderCat
in package for a dollar,
last year, that high.
When I walked, and it was late,
'cause now I'm taking my,
now its more like I'm doing
it for me and my kids.
It's like our bonding.
So I'm now waking them up at 4:30.
'Cause to get the real shit
you gotta get up early.
- Yeah, it's like Garage Wars.
- Yeah, so this is like I'm
leaving at like you know,
nine o'clock, it's loser
shit 'cause the kids.
But, I'm still getting to Jersey by 10:00.
So I don't think I'm getting anything.
It's more about buying them shit
and getting them in on the game.
But fuckin' at noon, noon!
I don't know what the fuck
people were doing, on a Saturday.
I pull up to this house, I look.
ThunderCat, in package.
I go "how much do you want for that?"
She goes,
"A dollar?"
I go, okay.
- Which one was it?
- Uh, Mumm-Ra.
- Oh God, that's a jewel.
- I fuckin' grabbed it.
And I was like yo.
The high that I got,
compared to me closing an 11
million dollar deal right now.
- To Mumm-Ra.
- Not even close.
- You should call the game Mumm-Ra.
- And I'm talkin' like,
I mean the delta-like,
I can't replicate the high
of finding some shit in a garage sale
that I'd buy for a dollar
that's worth twenty and
I can not replicate that high.
The thrill of the hunt.
- You're speaking my language.
- Is that you?
- Yeah.
- You love that shit right?
- Full time reseller.
So, I thrift all day every day.
- I get it man.
- I'm into fashion so I'm
looking for vintage clothing
and stuff like that.
- Give me something.
Give me the last find
you found that was crazy.
Like real crazy.
- Well I mean I found
a pair of Gucci loafers
for like 15 bucks a couple of days ago.
- Damn
- But like I find stuff every day.
Like I found--
- Where, like Goodwill?
- Yeah, Goodwill just all kind,
but I shop like suburbs.
- That's, that's yeah.
- I don't like metropolitan areas.
- Of course, too many,
it's supply and demand.
- But yeah, I found up here in The Bronx
a few years ago I found a pair of like
Kidrobot Air Max 1s.
I don't know if you guys
know what those are.
- Of course.
- There's a store in Soho, Kidrobot.
- I know Kidrobot for real, for real.
- I found--
- That was the whole Kidrobot,
Bape, like 2005, 2000, yeah.
- I found those for like nine bucks
and sold them for $1500.
- Wow.
- So I mean stuff like that all the time.
- You wanna hear something
great, back to the Bronx.
Remember Thriftland?
- Mm hmm.
- Is it still there?
'Cause it used to be right
next to Yankee Stadium.
- Damn yeah, I don't
think it's there anymore.
- I don't think it's there anymore.
- I walked to the Thriftland in 1996,
I'd never gone before,
we went to a Yankee game.
I was like oh shit Thriftland,
let me walk in there.
'Cause I was against thrift stores,
because it was too expensive,
I was pure garage sale.
If it's over a dollar, fuck you.
Got it?
(mumbling)
Yeah like real, like--
- Pure garage sale.
- Mainly because I was
doing it pre-internet.
When I was buying like, a box
of He-mans for four bucks.
You know?
And LJN's, wrestlers,
- Yeah.
- I used to kill on that.
And then video games is
where I made my real.
- Low overhead, super low overhead.
- Just the fun.
- Video games was-
- That was the biggest arbitrage.
- That's how I used to
trade in high school,
in junior high I used to trade
video games to make money.
- 100%.
- Like rent them out.
- Yeah, yeah, here's my
Rad Racer, give it back.
- Give me $2.00.
Give me $2.00.
- Give it back in a week and then,
two days later you have to fight.
(laughing)
I remember, you know.
Nonetheless, I went to Thriftland-
I never went to the Yankee game.
I got there, this man, this is early,
this is before people were
buying video games like that.
This man had
2000 Atari games.
- Wow
- And 1000 Nintendo games.
So I started going through them.
Like, looking for the right shit.
And right away I found Crazy
Climber, For Atari 2600,
And manual, 180 bucks.
Right, and its a dollar a piece.
Right off the bat, a mail away game.
'Cause I fuckin', I used to memorize shit.
No phone.
- Yeah, you had to.
- Used to fuckin
literally stay up at night
for like four hours memorizing shit.
Figuring out which rock and
roll t-shirts were worth money
and which ones weren't.
Memorized everything.
So finally I was like, is the owner here?
'Cause I'm going through
them finding shit.
I was like nobody's been through here.
And this is like right
next to Yankee Stadium so I
was just like trying to find
like one little like nut.
You know?
And I'm like what?
(laughing)
He comes over, he was there, thank God.
I go how much if I bought
every video game you had?
He was like "What do you?"
You know, classic Bronx.
"What do you mean?"
I'm like okay, let me break it down.
If I buy all the video games, what price?
Can I get a volume discount?
He goes--
- Five dollars.
- He's like "I'll give you,
yeah, you could take half off."
He goes, "Take them all all?"
And this was back in the day
when I didn't have an ATM card.
And I used to carry money.
- Cash of course.
- You know, we're older right?
They don't know.
And now I got $4.00 on me at all times.
I used to, when I was 16 I had like
$2000 on me at all times.
Never knew when you were
gonna find something.
Fuckin' bought it all out.
It was the greatest day of like my life.
- What was the type of, what
kind of video games where they?
- Atari 2600 and Nintendo NES and it was,
I mean he had 17 Contras.
- Wow.
- 17 Contras.
Which are like $20 or $30 now.
I mean, that whole market has
gone up by like 100 percent.
- Totally.
- Like when people are
like yo Gary Vee Twitch,
you're on it, I'm like motherfucker,
I was on this shit before you were born.
- I was on a modem, what's a modem?
- Like, you know what I mean,
I was like fuckin,
I knew who Zelda was before
your mom and dad even kissed.
(laughing)
- You don't know nothing
about blowing out the tape.
- Anyway.
- But yeah so that's exciting.
- So that's awesome.
- Working on the AND1 documentary now,
the AND1 mix-tape documentary.
(mellow organ music)